-Our next guest is
a Grammy Award-winning musician
and founding member
of The Roots,
who you can see every night
on "The Tonight Show."
His fantastic documentary,
"Summer of Soul
(...or, When the Revolution
Could Not Be Televised)"
is nominated for an Oscar
for Best Documentary Feature
and is streaming now on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-We were constantly
being attacked
because we weren't
"Black enough."
Sometimes we were called
"the Black group
with the white sound."
We didn't like that.
We happened to be artists
who are Black
and our voices sound
the way they sound
and how do you color --
that used to be one
of our questions --
how do you color a sound?
That was one of the reasons
why performing in Harlem
was so important to us.
-Mm-hmm.
-[crying]
Because we wanted our people
to know what we were about
-Mm-hmm.
-and we were hoping
that they would receive us.
-♪ Come on, let ♪
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Questlove, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-How are you doing?
-A lot has changed since the
last time you were here.
We were talking about this film
coming out
and, since then, you won
a BAFTA, just this weekend,
-Yeah, yeah.
-Spirit Award.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Nominated for a Grammy.
Nominated for an Oscar.
How does it feel?
-Phew!
I'm living the dream.
-Yeah.
-This is living the dream.
Every day it's, you know --
I'm about to say something
cliché like,
"Every day is a winding road."
[ Laughter ]
No, but it literally is because,
you know,
at least with the music world,
I know, you know --
Using a Frisbee -- is that
too much of a '70s term?
-No, you can use that.
It's "Summer of Soul."
You can use a Frisbee.
-Okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm just saying that I don't
know how, you know.
At least I know, with the music,
what a goal is,
but in the movie world like
I just had no clue.
I just wanted to make
something really cool
and, hopefully, they were going
to show it in a few classrooms
and then maybe discover it
20 years from now,
like, "Yo, you know
Questlove did this thing?"
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, so.
-Well, you know, we were just
talking to Kenneth Branagh,
who, obviously, was
Oscar-nominated as well.
He said that you immediately
start hearing from everybody.
Did you hear
from so many people?
-Oh, man.
The amount of cold calling.
[ Laughter ]
You know, like, especially now,
in the age of like
where like bots
call your iPhone,
you don't know who to trust
and not to trust.
But one day I was like really,
really hungry
and my Postmates guy was taking
a little bit too long.
-Yeah.
-And so, you know,
it was like an hour
and 10 minutes.
-That's too long, yeah.
-I decided to ring the phone.
Even, you know,
even if it was a bot,
I was going to answer it
and, you know,
the person didn't say much
and I was like,
"Yes, on the da na na na floor!
The da na na na floor!
Apartment da na na na na!"
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"Uh, hello?"
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Yes.
Da na na na floor!"
He said, "Uh, this Barry."
I said, "Barry?"
And I looked at all the texts.
"The president's
calling you right now!
[ Laughter ]
The president!"
Like literally like I've missed
all my managers texting me
that Obama's about to call me
in a second.
-So you thought Barack Obama
was your Postmates.
-Right, but wait.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
But even he said, he said,
"Well, you think I'm a --
a Postmates?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Wait, you know
what Postmates is?"
[ Laughter ]
So. yeah, he was the first.
-"I thought it was you
and it was Postmates.
I just thought,
after people are presidents,
they take any job they can,
you know, find."
[ Laughter ]
-You know what, though?
I was so hungry at the time,
I kind of wished
it was Postmates.
[ Laughter ]
-How did you find out?
How did you find out
you were nominated?
-Oh, this is weird.
Okay, so,
you know,
around this time period,
like depending on how strong
your character is, as a human,
this is where you can
start getting caught
in kind of this endless yarn
of getting inside your head.
-Yes, of course.
-You know, Will Smith's book
just came out
and that was really like
probably one
of the most important books
I've ever read
because, really,
no one in hip hop
has allowed themselves
to be that vulnerable
and talk about feelings
and emotions and those things.
And so I kind of stalked
Will Smith.
Even though, like we're both
from West Philly,
like it was just casual,
"Hey, how are you doing?"
But, you know, I stalked him
and kind of made him
my de facto life coach.
[ Laughter ]
And so, you know,
Will has been trying to talk me
into like waking up at 4:00.
He wakes up every day at 4:30
in the morning and was like,
"Yo, you got to get up
at 4:30 in the morning.
Watch the sunrise.
Seize the day."
You know how Will Smith gets,
like super --
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, I was just like,
[ Yawns ] "Oh, okay,
I'll see you at 10:00 am.
Alright, I'll call you."
[ Laughter ]
And so, you know,
the day of the announcements,
I was like, "Alright, I'm going
to do this Will Smith thing
and get up at 4:30
in the morning."
So, like imagine the whole
Tom Cruise, "Risky Business,"
"Old Time Rock & Roll" sliding
across the dance floor,
turn off the music
and dancing in the house
in my underwear
and all that stuff,
in the shower and all
that stuff.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know,
I put my good suit on,
got everything ready,
and I was sitting there waiting
for my team to call,
ready, like,
"Okay, let's have this."
And, about 35 minutes later,
I hit my executive assistant,
Kathy, up and I was like,
"Yo, where you guys at?"
She's like, "Ahmir, it's Sunday.
This is not until Tuesday."
[ Laughter ]
-And I just sat there
like a fool in my suit.
Like my good suit,
my good Sunday suit, so.
I was humiliated.
I went back to bed.
I was so mad, man.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that makes sense
because I remember
they had a picture of you
the day you did get nominated.
Your suit was all wrinkly.
[ Laughter ]
The actual morning of it,
I stayed in my --
you know, all pandemic,
I lived in nothing
but Old Navy pajamas, so.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
One of the cool things
about this documentary,
you told me,
when you were last here,
is that people
were finding themselves
or finding their parents
-Yeah.
-in the audience
of this music festival
because there had never been
footage of it before.
Has that continued to happen
while it's gone out wider?
-Constantly.
Like the number one message
I get in my DMs is sort of like,
"Who knew my grandmom
was a hot girl?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-You know.
Like that's --
That's always the like,
"Who knew my grandma
was a hot girl?"
So, yeah, there's a lot
of that happening.
-It's so great, by the way,
for the grandma
who's always been like,
"I told you."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, absolutely.
No, like notable musicians
that I grew up listening to,
it's like,
"Yo, that's my fiancé/e at the
age of 14 in the front row,"
that sort of thing.
And,
yeah, every day,
it's like a brand new surprise.
Like you never know.
Like just this week
at the DGAs,
the Directors Guild thing,
you know, I'd kind of been
trailing Spielberg.
Like now that I'm allowed
in these spaces,
where you got to go to these
like different awards,
pre-awards things,
before the Oscars.
You know, I've seen Spielberg
about six times,
but I was like really sheepish.
Like in my mind, I was like,
"Okay, well,
I met Rita Moreno twice,
so that's kind of
like meeting Spielberg."
[ Laughter ]
Kind of like meeting Gayle
eight times
is knowing Oprah.
-That's one Oprah.
[ Laughter ]
-Right, exactly.
So, you know, after Rita
sort of recognized me
the fourth time, I'm like,
it's kind of like
knowing Spielberg.
Anyway, I decided,
"Okay, this is your moment."
And, you know,
I went up while sheepish,
like the Mean Joe Green
Coke commercial from the '70s,
like, "Um, sir, uh,
my name is, uh."
And Lin-Manuel
sort of sensing like --
Lin-Manuel is now like maybe
a junior in high school,
so he totally looked at me
like a freshman,
like he just cut to the chase.
"Yo, he directed
'Summer of Soul,'"
and literally,
like Spielberg just started
fanning out for three minutes.
[ Audience ohs ]
Like I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
He said, "I watched it
multiple times!
And da da da da."
And I just, you know.
But every day
has been like that.
-That's really wonderful, man.
That's so exciting.
I want to always ask,
when you're here,
because it's my favorite detail
about you.
I know you have an ever-growing
collection of vinyl albums.
What's the number you would put
on it right now?
-It's kissing 200,000.
-200,000?
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oh, my God.
Wait a minute.
-Yeah.
-This is like you remember
like "Good Times"?
Whenever, like, you know,
James Evans lost his job
and the audience starts --
"Ooh!"
-"Aah!"
[ Laughter ]
-I felt like I just delivered
bad news on "Good Times," like.
[ Laughter ]
I'm fired again!
"Aah!"
-They didn't react to it like,
"That's a cool thing."
[ Laughter ]
-They're like, "Awww!"
-No, but it's different now
because,
you know, like a lot
of libraries are closing,
you know, like colleges
are losing their jazz programs.
Maybe they're
all going digital.
So now you just got people
that are, you know,
libraries that have
60,000 pieces or whatever
or like, you know,
we used to have jukeboxes
in diners, so all those one-stop
shop guys that had like
500 copies of "Billie Jean,"
like it's just rotting
somewhere, you know.
So they were like, "Oh,
that Roots guy likes records.
Give it to him."
[ Laughter ]
My girlfriend's none too happy
about it, though, so.
-But it is a great
responsibility.
People give it to you
because I think
there's an assumption
that you will maintain it,
you will keep it safe.
-They know I don't want it
to go in the trash, but, really,
I don't have any use
for like 500 copies
of "Billie Jean."
But I do have 500 copies, so.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, congratulations
on the film.
Best of luck at the Oscars.
-Thank you so much.
-It's always nice to see you.
Questlove.
[ Cheering and applause ]
"Summer of Soul"
streaming on Hulu
and the film's soundtrack
is available as well.